[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR WHAT PURPOSE DOES THE
GENTLEMAN FROM FLORIDA RISE?
>> TO NOMINATE A CANDIDATE FOR
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> THE GENTLEMAN IS RECOGNIZED.
>> WELL, SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO DO
JOBS THAT WE DON'T REALLY WANT
TO DO, AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
DO JOBS THAT WE ARE CALLED TO DO
AND SO MY COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
NOMINATE THE MOST TALENTED,
HARDEST WORKING MEMBER OF THE
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE WHO JUST
GAVE A SPEECH WITH MORE VISION
THAN WE HAVE EVER HEARD FROM THE
ALTERNATIVE.
I AM NOMINATING JIM JORDAN IS
HUMBLE PERHAPS TODAY HUMBLED TO
A FAULT, AND MAYBE THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR THE JOB OF SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE ISN'T SOMEONE WHO
WANTS IT SO BAD.
MAYBE THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THE
JOB OF SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
ISN'T SOMEONE WHO HAS SOLD
SHARES OF THEMSELVES FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE TO GET IT.
MAYBE JIM JORDAN IS THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
BECAUSE HE IS NOT BEHOLDEN TO
THE LOBBYISTS AND SPECIAL
INTERESTS WHO HAVE CORRUPTED
THIS PLACE AND CORRUPTED THIS
NATION UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
BOTH REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
MAYBE JIM JORDAN WOULD BE THE
RIGHT PERSON FOR THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE WHEN HE WOULD NOT
FIGHT US WHEN WE TRY TO GET A
TERM LIMITS ON THE FLOOR, AND
MAYBE HE WOULD NOT FIGHT US WHEN
WE TRY TO PUT A BALANCED BUDGET
ON THE FLOOR, AND MAYBE JIM
JORDAN IS THE RIGHT PERSON,
BECAUSE HE WOULD PUT A PLAN TO
SECURE OUR BORDER TO THE FLOOR.
AND AS HE SAID, THERE ARE
CERTAIN BILLS THAT WE NEED TO
PASS TO GET TO THE FLOOR, AND
THE CHALLENGE IS THAT THE PERSON
WHO IS VOTING FOR THESE BILLS
HAVE CAUSED THESE PROBLEM, AND
MR. JORDAN SAYS THAT WE CANNOT
ACCEPT THE BILLS LIKE THE
OMNIBUS, AND I AGREE, AND IF HE
WERE THE LEADER OF THE
REPUBLICAN TEAM, WE WOULD NOT
HAVE THAT CIRCUMSTANCE CHOKING
THE COUNTRY'S ECONOMY AND
CHOKING THE PROSPECT OF LIFE FOR
OUR FELLOW AMERICAN, AND FINALLY
MR. JORDAN SAID THAT WE MUST
ENGAGE IN RIGOROUS OVERSIGHT,
AND EVERY ONE OF THE REPUBLICANS
KNOWS THAT THE PERSON WHO CAN
LEAD THAT OVERSIGHT WHO WORKS ON